♪ Music playing ♪
[KNOCKING]
This feels wrong.
We're disturbing
his sacred solitude.
We shouldn't have come.
♪
This scene
is Henry David Thoreau,
naturalist and writer,
being a real jerk to two guests,
George and Emily.
You're going to entertain
your guests half naked?
These are not my guests because
I didn't even invite them.
He's a little bit of a letdown.
[LAUGHS]
But in a funny way.
I'd rather sit on a pumpkin
and have it all to myself
than be crowded
on a velvet cushion.
Write that down.
He's a naturalist.
She assumes he'll be a good man.
He's not.
Why do I care about your tree?
You said you loved the woods.
- I love my woods.
Everyone really makes it big
during their lifetime --
they become insufferable.
Emily Dickinson didn't get
to become big in her lifetime.
Henry David Thoreau did,
and he was insufferable.
You're a dick!
- Never meet your heroes.
♪
[SLAM]